let's go - why don't we go to our caller
from the 5:1 - area code who's calling
today from 5:1 - yes yes it is who's
this likewise I have 2 options for you
would you like a fun and silly question
or a more serious question
give me the fun and silly first okay
well you rarely talk about sports being
that you're a political commentator but
when you do you always mention how much
you love Argentine football and
especially Lionel Messi right
would you how do you feel about people
grown grown adults specifically who wear
sports jerseys listen look the sports
jersey sorry are you talking about on
game day or like to work um either way I
mean it makes no difference to me as
long as you're not being paid to
actually do the sport for the jersey
you're wearing right so listen here's my
view I actually the jersey thing I don't
really care about that much but here's
something I have been thinking about
lately I used to watch every Red Sox
game I would watch every Celtics game I
would watch every Patriots get you know
I was really a fan and I couldn't
imagine when I was 16 17 18 even 22 I
couldn't imagine a time where that
wouldn't be a huge part of my life and
then as I continued to develop in my
career and to start valuing certain
other things including relationships and
paying more attention to you know the
political world and valuing spending
more time reading and all of these
things uh it's it's actually hard to fit
in following the teams that I like
nearly as much as I did at one point but
more interestingly there was a period
where I felt bad about it but now I
actually see you know 55 year olds who
are like you're saying wearing the
jersey all the time watching every game
going crazy acting acting out in many
ways and I don't totally get it it does
strike me as a little
a bit weird because it's just like it's
hard for me I guess given everything
that's going on in the world and
everything that ones focus can be on I'm
a casual fan and I get being a casual
fan for life but some of the extreme
fandom particularly in middle age does
strike me as a little bit weird I do
admit that okay I was just curious also
would you like a Sergio agüero Jersey no
I don't need any jerseys so please keep
all of the jerseys I am all good with
jerseys I have more than enough jerseys
for for what for my life right now but I
do appreciate it
yes sir David thank you so much you have
a great day
all right great to hear from you I
appreciate it on that note let's go to a
break I'm sorry I couldn't get to
everyone I never can but I hope to talk
to many of you folks again next time we
take calls quick break back after this